why don't women like short men right
okay one side of it could be beauty
standards who made those other men other
men are the ones who have said you have
to be told to be considered manly that's
because of y'all that's one two we're
gonna put a pause right there what she
does that's incoherent she says I am
independent minded I'm I'm smarter than
all of you people you need to listen to
me I see things correctly I'm an
empowered woman I set the rules I do
whatever I want but also men have all
the control and they're the only people
with agency and women can't do anything
do you see the conflict there do you see
that problem which is not just her
problem it's an incoherence at the heart
of feminism women have absolutely no
control or agency to set beauty
standards to to do anything at all and
also women have all the agency and
Independence in the world and they don't
need a man and a woman needs a man like
a fish needs a bicycle I'm a woman hear
me roar